Hello, everybody. Welcome to another podcast today. We have a great guest who's been a friend of mine since. Hello. We know each other.
It's probably been about seven years seven years. Dr. Elliott her short and his wife who's a doctor in their clinic as well. Have a
clinic a new life medical center. You actually have multiple clinics, though, right? Yeah, we are working on that. Yes, in process. That's pretty cool. And South Carolina,
which is a long way for Minnesota and probably a lot warmer. Indeed it is. Yes, Minnesota, especially this time of year.
And what we want to talk about is this new piece of equipment that you started with a little over a year ago.
You've been how I got to know you. Let's take a step back as in functional medicine, functional neurology seminars.
You are a functional neurologist. You do functional medicine, so we practice much the same way that way.
You know, I veered off at all we do is with cancer patients, though, you still work with a lot of other conditions.
And that's what I like to bring out of this podcast is so that so our our patients from all around the country can get to know people like you and be helped.
Because people can have more than one condition going on, right? Right. So they got neuropathy or they have headaches or they have, you know, whatever else they have that they could be helped by somebody just like you.
Well, this new piece of equipment that I'm excited to talk about is Sadexas and I'm going to just turn it over to you because not very many clinics have this. Correct. Yeah, it's taking off now.
But we've been doing it for about a year. It's Sadexas a machine that we use as a part of a combination therapy called combine electrochemical treatment or CET for short.
And basically combines the electrical stimulation and activation of the nerves and the muscles with targeted and local injections of nutrients to help with the healing and repair of the nerves.
So a lot of our patients that benefit from it have chronic pain or arthritis and then neuropathy as well.
So that kind of fits right in with cancer for those patients that are undergoing chemotherapy oftentimes will get the neuropathy and treatment is safe to do alongside of chemotherapy for those patients that might be experiencing neuropathy.
So I understand it's an FDA approved approach. So it's covered by most insurances and Medicare. Is that right.
It is. Yeah. So the machine is cleared by the FDA to treat all cute and chronic pains. So therefore most insurances will pick it up and towards when you do the combination of the electrical treatment with the nutrient injections.
And they are really both vitally important parts of the treatment and they kind of work synergistically together for the healing process. But yeah, it is cleared by the FDA.
The equipment and it is covered by most insurances including Medicare.
So let's walk through that's a let's say I have a patient with severe neuropathy from chemotherapy.
So it's a let's say it's in both their lower legs below the knee. What would you do for them?
So we have them come in. They made with one of our case managers initially to see, you know, what's going on. If it's a good fit, you know, our office is going to be most appropriate for them. And then they meet with one of our medical providers.
It's usually our nurse practitioner who will do an exam kind of determine what the severity of the neuropathy is, what the prognosis will look like in terms of, you know, the treatment is going to be appropriate for them.
We also have some other types of treatment that we may add on to that in addition to the CET. But that's kind of the foundation, especially for the neuropathy treatment.
And then we will start them on a series of treatments. They'll come in typically two to three times a week for that treatment.
And each time they come in, they'll do the electrical stimulation that's preceded, however, by the nutrient injections.
I don't know who named it CET, but that's just kind of how it's described in literature.
But the chemical part is, it's not so much chemicals as it is the nutrients. So there's a bunch of key vitamins and antioxidants and minerals and nutrients that really help with the healing and repair of the nerves.
And the way I describe it, the patient says just like a woman who's pregnant has to take prenatal vitamins in order for proper development of the baby's brain.
It's the same thing if we want to get healing and repair of the nerves in your feet and legs, we have to deliver those nutrients directly into the site that we're trying to get healing and repair to occur.
So that's what we do with the nutrients. And then the electrical stimulation, it by itself, helps to activate the neurons, which is important, as you know, from a functional morality standpoint to get healing to occur.
It also stimulates the muscles and helps we have those. But then just from a kind of an effective standpoint with the nutrients that actually helps to derive those nutrients that ion to a freezes effect down into the deeper tissues to where they need to go to do their work as well.
So it really is a synergistic.
Now you've been doing this for a while.
Well, we started doing it in December of 2018. So just over here, could you give me some like case stories of what are the results that you've had?
Yeah, so one comes to mind is a patient that had a foot drop.
So she had a foot drop to the extent that she could not drive anymore. So it significantly limited her ability to just function independently.
And so she came in and was evaluated. She went through the treatment program. And by the end, not only was her pain gone, which is, you know, important for quality of life issues, but she was able to drive by the time she was working with us.
So a significant improvement in function and obviously symptoms.
Or was that over the course of 12 weeks?
Yeah, I think hers was about 12 weeks. It's typically eight to 12 weeks as the initial treatment period that we start with depending on the severity.
Wow, that's that's fascinating.
So how about like with the people with knee pain or hip pain, I think of some older patients that are thinking about getting, you know, hip surgery and replacement.
Could this push that out into the distance a little bit?
Yeah, absolutely. So the machine itself, because it involves some, it's also indicated by the FDA or the FDA for neuromuscular reeducation.
And that's just that you know, as you know, a fancy word to say that it can help reeducate or retrain the muscles. So it kind of acts like a passive or almost a replacement for active rehab of joints.
So you can put it around the joint knee or a hip and help to reeducate those muscles, get them to function more appropriately.
At the same time, it's helping to reduce pain and reduce information, increase blood flow to the area.
So we can definitely see improvement in pain, range of motion function in joints as well.
Now we'll often couple that with regenerative medicine injections if we're talking about a joint.
There's some, you know, if somebody's got active cancer, we're not going to do that. But that's, you know, becomes a really good alternative for someone who can't do or doesn't want to do surgery.
Can you regenerate a medicine because they have active cancer and they really want to get some of your leaf on their joints? This is a really good option for that.
Okay. How about is it, is it a painful process?
So the, you know, the most pain that people are going to experience is with the injection part.
So a lot of times though, if they have neuropathy, their feet are numb and they don't feel it anyway.
So when they start feeling it, that's actually a good indication that it's working.
And we have different topical anesthetic type things that will do it patients prefer that so that it's more comfortable.
A couple of seconds to do that right before the machine is hooked up, but the machine itself is not painful.
It feels like a light tingling or vibrations sensation. It's actually very relaxing and comfortable for the patient.
So, and that's that lasts up to 30 minutes. So it's good that that's not that part's not painful. It's just a comfortable kind of tingling or vibration feeling.
Sure. Now you said that the country education would be not doing it over any active cancer, but are there other country indications?
Anybody with a pacemaker or, you know, other health conditions that can't really use this?
Yeah, so we can do the electrochemical treatment, the combine of CET on people that have cancer.
It was the regenerative medicine. I was talking about that we can't do active cancer.
But for the CET, yeah, you do have to be careful with any electrical devices that are implanted.
So if they have a pacemaker or especially a pacemaker defibrillator, it is caused for concern, but we will often, or we will always get approval from cardiology.
So it's not a hard and fast rule out in terms of a pacemaker.
So as long as their cardiologist will approve the treatments, then we can proceed with that. We've actually had representatives from the device company come to the office to monitor the patient on their first treatment to make sure everything was going well.
And then we got the final approval after that.
So as long as their cardiologist is willing to invest a little bit of time to make sure that it's appropriate and not just completely right it off.
Sometimes it can be beneficial even if people have a pacemaker.
Yeah, I know in the past, we did a lot of more electrical systems as long as you're doing the lower extremities, you were safe with a defibrillator.
You can tell me any other super things that you've seen happen with it. It's an exciting therapy.
We just have a lot of patients with those kind of conditions that I just know the world is filled with people with pain and neuropathy and when I think I read somewhere that it's that falling is the number one cause of death to people over a certain age, and it's because they can't feel their feet.
Yeah, so you know, obviously our goal is to help people avoid medications and surgery and you're right in our older population.
Their falls are one of the leading cause of death and disability.
So if we can help them avoid medication surgery and help them avoid injury by getting those nerves back online, it's a huge win obviously for the patient.
It does improve balance too. So we do kind of back up a little bit in terms of the initial work up with the patient.
We do, we have a balanced platform. So we measure their balance and baseline quantitatively.
So it gives us a number in terms of their fall risk and then we reassess that as we move forward.
So we do see improvement in their balance and stability, which is good.
And then one of the other things that's been most beneficial for us talking about this with other medical providers is that we actually do before and after biopsy of their small fiber nerves.
So it's a little punch biopsy. They take a little piece of the skin in a couple places on their leg.
It goes off to a lab. They measure how many small fiber nerves there are, which are the ones that are associated with the pain and the temperature and those types of things.
It's different from the NCV. A lot of our patients have had that nerve induction velocity test where they stick all the needles in, but that only measures large fibers.
So oftentimes they have never had their small fibers measure. So anyway, we send this biopsy out. We get it back and it gives us their score of small fiber density and function compared to a standard.
And it tells us do you do they actually have small fiber neuropathy, but then that's sort of as a baseline, because we'll repeat the test afterwards.
And this is really the most fascinating thing from a clinical perspective for me and for sharing with other providers is that we actually demonstrated nerve regrowth with the therapy and almost all the patients that we've done this on.
So whereas in the beginning, they may have one or two nerves in this site, then afterwards they could have 10 or 12 nerves and we've demonstrated up to 600% increase in nerve density with this dream.
That's talk about really being able to define the healing through laboratory testing. That's just fantastic. So a lot of you must be encouraged to that.
Absolutely. And that's what makes it kind of real world for the traditional medical physicians that we go into their office and say, hey, we want to help your patients with neuropathy because really they're only tools are to have a pentin.
But then they're like, well, where's the research and we just show them look what here's a before biopsy here's an after one. And there's nothing you can't refute that.
The real results, not only is the patient feeling better and functioning better, but there's actually nerves that have regrown in there.
Well, Dr. Elliott, how can people find you? We're going to put your website up and I want you to say it.
Our website is new life medical centers with an s dot com so they can go there learning a little bit more about the treatments. They can also go see some testimonials on there. It can also go to Greenville.
neuropathy care dot com. And that has a little bit more information about the specific ct treatment that we've talked about as well.
Okay, we'll get it up on the videos so everybody can see that because we want people to take advantage of this new therapies.
We're all into new therapies and we can change the way a person lives, you know, through therapy instead of having to be in medication with all these side effects that work very well.
Well, I appreciate you and I appreciate your care for people and your sharing the information and this all came about because I actually had a patient that asked on our patient Facebook page.
Can I do this in excess and I said, well, I know the person who does it. So I'll get a little podcast going with Dr. Elliott. So I appreciate that.
Absolutely. We'll have you back talking about some other subjects and thanks again.
Thank you. Take care.
Bye-bye.